le projet plutôt ambitieux voire même
prétentieux car il faudra des centaines
de millions d'euros pour améliorer
l'état de santé de la population et
réduire les inégalités sociales et
territoriales comme ses représentants le
préconise l'hôpital public est moribond
depuis trop longtemps la dette et le
déficit cumulé frise le milliard d'euros
impossible de revenir à l'équilibré ou
donc trouver les fonds pour mettre en
pratique ce projet de santé régional
financement il faut savoir que il en
manquera toujours parce que la santé
certains un coup mais ça n'a pas de prix
il faut bien comprendre que des
financements importants existent sont
déjà disponibles un premier travail à
faire c'est de
invitée inciter à mieux les utiliser et
je disais qu'il ne manquera toujours et
c'est là que la rs ministère d'état
prendront toute leur classe pour
accompagner l'innovation une meilleure
prise en charge des patients le
développement de certains services le
recrutement de médecins et notamment de
spécialistes ce sont les priorités de ce
projet de santé sauf que la réalité est
telle que même certains parlementaires
ont du mal à se projeter sur l'avenir
sanitaire du pays
selon jean-philippe ni lors
l'administration elle-même participe à
la désertification sanitaire s'est pas
seulement avec des plans comme ça qu'ils
sont séduisants sur le papier sur
l'écran quand nous allons nous en sortir
mais en mettant en oeuvre des
dispositions et une volonté farouche
d'améliorer de préserver et de réparer
ce qui a été commis au détriment de la
santé de nos compatriotes au delà de ces
beaux discours il ya des problèmes des
verrous qui persistent qui subsistent
comme par exemple les difficultés qu'on
a pour recruter des médecins de haut
niveau des médecins étrangers qui
souhaitent venir
l'administration française pose tous les
obstacles toutes les entraves à ce
rythme là la rs projette d'organiser des
réunions publiques pour que chaque
citoyen participe à l'orientation de son
système de santé
[Musique]